derzeit wird beim klimagipfel in glasgow
darüber diskutiert wie wir die
klimaschutzziele erreichen sollen ich
finde gut dass ist in deutschland
mittlerweile konsens ist dass wir nicht
darüber diskutieren ob wir die
klimaschutzziele erreichen wollen
sondern wie wir das am besten tun was
mir sorge macht ist dass es viele länder
in der welt gibt die versuchen wollen
den verbrennungsmotor in deutschland und
den anderen ländern zu verbieten die
sich dafür einsetzen dass es diese
technologie in zukunft nicht mehr geben
wird das halte ich aus unterschiedlichen
gründen für falsch erstens gibt es sehr
viele forscher die den verbrennungsmotor
schon in kürzester zeit klimaneutral
machen können zum beispiel mit die man
neutralen kraftstoffe aber bei der
ganzen klimadiskussion müssen wir auch
an die vielen hunderttausenden
arbeitsplätze in der deutschen
automobilindustrie zu denken wenn der
klima wenn der verbrennungsmotor einfach
verboten wird obwohl er sogar
klimaneutral betrieben werden kann dann
wäre das ein großes problem denn es
würde zu einem sozialen kahlschlag
kommen viele regionen würden in
deutschland darunter leiden und deswegen
finde ich es richtig dass wir in
deutschland uns dafür einsetzen dass wir
technologieoffen rangehen und dass wir
sagen wenn der verbrennungsmotor wie man
neutral betrieben werden kann dann
sollten wir in deutschland das auch
unterstützen viele hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze hängen daran applaus sehe
ich ganz genauso
und vor allem man sagt ja immer die
elektroautos meinte schon das gefühl
wenn das elektroauto fährt daran ist
alles toll das elektroauto das bringt
uns also darin ist alles toll was
natürlich stimmt ist dass co2 frei ist
aber was ist eigentlich mit den
batterien das finde ich ein ganz ganz
spannend punkt denn wenn wir nur noch
elektroautos produzieren würden wir uns
eine geopolitische abhängigkeit begeben
denn die batterien werden vor allem in
china hergestellt im kongo ich habe mal
noch weiter recherchiert russland
indonesien und chile wenn man sich das
anschaut dann muss man ja mal sagen okay
wollen wir das als die grundlage haben
elektroautos ist wir uns damit auch
verbünden und deswegen ist meine frage
ob wir uns wirklich diese abhängigkeit
auch begeben sollten oder jetzt nicht
lieber mehrspurig fahren sollten das
heißt den verbrenner noch weiter nutzen
beide haben sie auch schon darauf
hingewiesen man kann ihn ja auch anders
nutzen das ist ja nicht der verbrenner
der schlimmes sollen das ist das benzin
und da muss natürlich weiter geforscht
werden dass der polen also entscheidend
ist natürlich was kippt man da rein
genau also wenn wir am ende kraftstoffe
rein kippen die auf strom basieren und
die am ende im gesamtprozess dafür
sorgen dass alles co2 neutrales warum
soll ich dann sagen aus ideologischen
gründen werden jetzt verbrennungsmotoren
verboten ich finde es sehr bedenklich
und das treibt mir auch gewisse
sorgenfalten auf die stirn dass die
grünen auch teile der spd jetzt in der
ampelkoalition versuchen den
verbrennungsmotor zu verbieten weil er
wirklich ganz viele arbeitsplätze daran
hängen und am ende sorgt dann dafür dass
auch das wichtige thema klimaschutz
immer weniger gesellschaftliche
akzeptanz bekommen ja und die zweite
punkt ist ja man müsste jetzt eigentlich
weiter forschen bei den synthetischen
kravchenko das ist klar das ist ja der
punkt das könnte man den nutzen anstatt
des benzins und dann der ist ja sogar
gut in verbrenner genau richtig und
deswegen finde ich es ganz toll das
system heute gefragt würde ich heute
merke ich habe der leidenschaft für den
verbrenner eine frage hätte ich doch die
cdu wollte auch regieren auch mit den
grünen zusammen glauben sie dass man den
ausstieg aus dem verbrennungsmotor da
nicht beschlossen hätte ist jetzt alles
natürlich hypothetisch aber wir haben
sehr viel wert darauf gelegt auch damals
in unserem wahlprogramm dass der
verbrennungsmotor weiter erhalten bleibt
wenn er klimaneutral betrieben wird also
es war für uns immer ein ganz wichtiger
punkt da hätten wir auch druck gemacht
ist aber natürlich als hypothetisch weil
wir ja nicht in verhandlungen stecken
und ich glaube es gibt noch einen
weiteren wichtigen aspekt der bei der
ganzen debatte mal viel zu wenig
berücksichtigt wird wir haben selbst
wenn wir alle ziele bei der
elektromobilität für zwanzig dreißig
erreichen immer noch im nächsten
jahrzehnt 30 bis 35 millionen verbrenner
auf den straßen so die müssen ja auch
irgendwie klimafreundlich klimaschutz
betrieben werden also wir jetzt aber
sagt es wird nicht mehr an der
verbrenner technologie geforscht fuels
werden verboten synthetischer
kraftstoffe werden verboten dann wird
man 20 30 gleich die klimaschutzziele
erreichen können immobilität 2 die
synthetischen kraftstoff sind ja gerade
noch zu teuer da muss ich bleiben ja
gerade noch zu teuer deswegen müssen wir
da weiter daran forschen des teams nicht
dass auch ein guten aufruf aber
natürlich hat philipp ihr tor für immer
recht die union hätte dann natürlich
auch in den letzten jahren etwas anders
agieren aber wir haben das schon immer
unterstützt ja ich mehr hat die union
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen gefehlt als
verteidiger des deutschen autors also
das deutsche auto ja klar auch als immer
als teil der kultur ist teil der
volksseele aber auch eben als wichtiger
teil der volkswirtschaft und es gab im
letzten jahren einfach wahnsinnig viele
angriffe auf das automobil auf den
verbrenner und meter hat die
selbstbewusste union die sie wirklich
davor stellt und nicht wie armin laschet
sagt wir müssen ökologie und ökonomie
verein und kein mensch versteht was
diese floskeln bedeutet dass er mit
total gefehlt was ist tatsächlich hier
sehr merkwürdig ist bei einigen debatten
deutschlands glaube ich das einzige land
in der welt in dem man sich dafür
rechtfertigen muss wenn man was für eine
schlüsselindustrie tut und wenn man sich
für 100000 arbeitsplätze einsetzt also
ich habe im bundestag ja auch einige
debatten erlebt da habe ich mich für die
deutsche automobilindustrie eingesetzt
und für die arbeitsplätze die dranhängen
mein kampf der vorwurf von den grünen
sie sind hier irgendwie anwalt der
deutschen automobilindustrie in brüssel
und er sagt dass man auch alle anderen
europäischen länder auch dass die gucken
wie kann man auch die heimische
wirtschaft stärken und ich glaube da
brauchen wir tatsächlich auch in
deutschland ein mentalitätswechsel in
den ganzen tag wir dürfen auch die
automobilzulieferer nicht vergessen als
ich eine riesige industrie die
automobilzulieferer sitzen teilweise in
kleinregion sind super wichtig dort auch
für die städte für die kommunen aber was
ich da sagen muss philipp da sich auch
er die wirtschaft in der schuld weil ich
meine die automobilindustrie hat sich ja
so sehr auf den boden gelegt drei mal
schon versteckt anstatt zu kämpfen ja
also das muss man wirklich sagen ich
meine allein die allen masc angebetet
wird und alle anderen von der
automobilindustrie das wundert mich auch
manchmal warum die nicht einfach mehr
kämpfen und nicht etwas dagegen tun dass
der verbrenner so verteufelt wurde da
würde ich gerne herrn kessler eine frage
gestellt da bin ich gespannt sie sind
zwar deutscher journalisten ja aber bei
der neuen züricher zeitung bei der nzz
mit ihrem journalistisch schweizerischen
blick wie schauen sie denn darauf dass
die deutsche schlüsselindustrie gerade
dabei ist sich selbst abzuschaffen naja
die die schweizer verstehen diese
rituelle selbstentladung nicht das muss
man schon sagen german engineering hat
oder hatte muss man sagen weltruf und
die schweizer als ein liberales oder
freisinnige volk das gleichzeitig auch
noch relativ technik affin ist versteht
also diese vorauseilende bereitschaft
auf fortschritt durch technologie zu
verzichten bei den deutschen nicht auch
der beispielsweise hauruck vollzogene
ausstieg aus der atomkraft wird in
deutschland nicht verstanden man sieht
viel deutlicher dass wettbewerb dass
märkte über wettbewerb funktionieren
dass deutschland einen wettbewerb
teilweise gar nicht aufnimmt wo man es
aufnehmen müsste weil es an kreativität
fehlt an kreativität haben in
deutschland eine unterentwickelte
unternehmen und kultur wir haben eine
unterentwickelte kreativität wir haben
keine kultur des scheiterns die jetzt
auch geben muss um kreativ zu werden und
vor allen dingen operieren wir lieber
mit begriffen als mit kompetenzen und
das sind wir auch bei dieser sache wir
reden alle auch die cdu auch in laschet
von der notwendigkeit der transformation
es wird aber nicht ausformuliert wer
sich den zu was bitteschön
transformieren muss und wer am wegesrand
zurück bleibt er habe gesagt immerhin es
wird opfer geben aber was wird er sein
eine massenarmut ich hoffe nicht
zumindest ist diese transformation führt
diesmal paradigmatisch jetzt
energiewende nehme nicht durchdacht und
die opfer wenn einfach einen schein
jetzt glaube ich dass man die politik
muss die ziele definieren und muss sagen
so das müssen alle erreichen aber auf
welchem wege das geschieht sich in die
höhe halten genau die leute unternehmen
und verbrauchern überlassen sein also
wenn wir es schaffen nur mit
batteriegetriebene elektromobilität alle
ziele zu erreichen und alle wollen dass
in deutschland dann sage ich okay gerne
das entscheidet ja in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft scheinen das unternehmen
und verbraucher wenn aber es auch ein
wichtiger teil sein können der lösung
war ich dann sagen wie die grünen aus
ideologischen gründen wenn aber jetzt
verbrennungsmotoren verboten das glaube
ich verstehen nur wenige aber was sagen
sie denn dann zu vw dieser konzern ist
ja gerade wirklich staatstreue als der
staat die wollen ja das benzin teurer
wird die wollen die setzt nur noch auf
elektro die wollen natürlich früher
desto besser aus und 15er aussteigen was
ist haben mit dem konzern aber wenn man
das ist eigentlich ein gutes beispiel
für das was ich eben gesagt habe weil
die deutschen autobauer haben
unterschiedliche strategien vw setzt im
moment fast nur auf bei der
registrierung elektromobilität bmw zum
beispiel ist sehr dafür dass es auch ios
gibt und dass der verbrennungsmotor eine
zukunft hat auch zb daimler sagt
wasserstoff muss auch in zukunft eine
rolle spiele also dass wasserstoff
antriebe könnten möglicherweise auch
teil der lösung sein und ich finde die
politik sollte den unternehmen gar nicht
vorschreiben was sie jetzt machen da
kann es ja auch wettbewerb geben die
einsätzen mehr auf batterie die anderen
auf andere technologien aber die politik
sollte nicht wie in der planwirtschaft
von oben sagen habt ihr müsst jetzt
diesen weg einschlagen liebe unternehmen
aber in diese richtung geht es doch
befürchtet und auch
mitgebracht weil ich fand sehr gut dass
auch auf drängen jetzt der cdu in
glasgow dieser punkt des papiers nicht
unterschrieben wurde weil das hier in
deutschland wirklich hunderttausende
arbeitsplätze am ende kosten könnte aber
es kann sein dass in der ampel am ende
herauskommt dass der verbrennungsmotor
keine zukunft hat und da haben wir
eigentlich noch ein verbrennungsmotor zu
hause und was war persönlich noch nie
ein auto gehabt also weder auto noch
nimmt also ich fand nur in hamburg und
er grün wie wir in wasser elektroauto
verbrenner wie siehst du die zukunft
verbrenner ja also ich tatsächlich kenne
ich mich in dem thema nicht so sehr aus
dass ich jetzt hier wirklich
mitreden kann deswegen halte ich mich da
lieber zurück aber ich sehe es auch
schwierig umsetzbar so zum beispiel wie
stellt man sich das in afrika vor so
soll man da irgendwie soll man da an
jeder ecke irgendwie eine teststation
aufbauen wie soll das funktionieren ja
vor allem müssten ja auch die dritte
welt länder wie auch motorisiert werden
also dafür werden wir definitiv
verbrenner brauchen ist ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt in new york dass das hat
ein ganz wichtiger punkt weil ich habe
manchmal den eindruck einige wollen die
klimaschutzziele und das große thema wie
entwickelt sich das weltklima nur
national lösen gerade die grünen aber es
gibt auch bei der spd sehr viele die so
denken und es bringt uns nichts wenn wir
sagen wir haben in deutschland zum
beispiel
alles erfüllt aber die ganzen autos
kommen nach afrika und dort steigt dann
der co2 ausstoß sondern ich muss doch
gerade bei diesem thema klimaschutz
international agieren und auch
international denken also weg von dieser
nationalen brille und deswegen sind die
eh fuels da auch eine wichtige lösung
war natürlich wird es wahrscheinlich in
fünf oder zehn jahren so so sein dass in
jedem afrikanischen land an fast jeder
straße irgendwie eine ladesäule steht
bei der man ein elektroauto mit strom
tanken kann